[Музика]
видання видаляє те, що Гітлер
розкидали неправдиву інформацію
його гладка брехня і його багато
напівправда на чисто
досягти пропагандистського ефекту
[Музика]
які праві тенденції
дають серед покупців але це є
є освіченими громадянами навіть учителями
Я думаю, відносно багато вчителів, але
інакше просто історичний
зацікавлених осіб було можливо
трохи дивне відчуття настільки
У мене також були б можливості для продажу титулу
не дуже добре, але зрештою, якщо ви
скажіть, що ви повинні прочитати цю книгу цей текст
порушувати табу
то теж добре, якщо що на
багато також приходить, і я знаходжу це
насправді добре, що інститут для
сучасна історія теж велика
З цією книгою я досяг успіху в продажах
думаю, що добре, що їх так багато в
Коментована версія тепер у багатьох
слід зберігати
[Музика]